you know it is said that consciousness
is mediated by chemistry you know our
moods our dances of chemistry occurring
in our brains and bodies and we can
mediate this chemistry this
psychopharmacology through the ingestion
of drugs but also through the
participation in certain activities
through placing the body mind in certain
spaces and places a beautiful cathedral
a beautiful museum a beautiful building
or structure can architect a particular
flavor of consciousness in fact even the
placebo effect is not really an illusion
because real chemistry is being is
happening in our brains when we believe
that what we're taking is going to
affect how we think and so our moods are
mediated by mind by world by chemistry
and it makes you wonder if the words of
David Pierce the philosopher who wrote
the hedonistic imperative should perhaps
be taking a little more seriously he
talks about designing new mind where for
ourselves he talks about designer drugs
that will allow us to program gradients
of consciousness that take us to spaces
and places and blissful mind-body states
that we cannot even fathom I mean he
basically says we can become paradise
engineers and that it is our moral
responsibility to sort of create these
prescriptions of mind for ourselves to
to basically deconstruct an engineer
Nirvana right to create virtual
realities that we can inhabit and
believe in and suspend disbelief within
and accept new software for the mind
right upgrade the posthuman gets to
inhabit spaces of subjectivity that will
make the old world seem barbaric by
comparison I think it is our
responsibility as the meaning makers as
the dreamers of dreams to turn all of
interior life into a poem a living
dynamic living breathing work of art you
see festivals like Burning Man these
gatherings that bring in hundreds of
thousands of people to try to turn the
world to turn the stage in which we
dwell into something more beautiful
something with a little more compassion
a little more empathy a little more
grace gratitude and bliss to D Center
the ego right to transcend Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and to go somewhere
deeper and higher is this possible for
ourselves you know there's experiments
right we've seen people try to do it
creating these heterotopia as these
temporary spaces in which it seems like
it's possible but then you watch the
news the doom and gloom the terrorist
threats and you get a little bit
depressed it makes me think that the
goal that the mission that that the end
game might not be possible because
there's too many people conspiring
against it but I remain steadfast that
we can't give up right beauty will win
love will win aesthetic you know
aesthetic arrest transformation
illumination grace these are the things
that worth that are worth you know
fighting for and working for yeah I get
the press sometimes and I watch TV but
then I want to go make more videos and
put more Beauty out into the world and
induce goosebumps Rhapsody and rapture
for all that's what I want